l'enjeu est de taille pour la jeune
martiniquaise dès le premier tour dieu
veut la gaspard est opposée à la tête de
série numéro 5
une britannique aux portes du tennis
professionnel 500e l'an dernier au
classement wta
emilie ap le town finaliste l'an dernier
est venu prendre une revanche franchir
un à un les tour de ce tournoi
international pour cette fois soulever
le trophée qui lui a échappé en 2018
entre les deux jeunes femmes une
différence de niveau et d'expérience
mais chacune s'est battu pour son
objectif j'essaie de travailler
plusieurs choses comme mes revers pour
essayer de les placer dans le match pour
qu'à chaque match je joue de mieux en
mieux travailler son revers peut-être
car son coup droit a déjà malmené la
martiniquaise du fond du court et millet
ap le town joue avec des accélérations
et des effets qu'ils ne le seront que
peu de chance à dieu la gaspard pour
marquer au score le match les formateurs
je prends de l'expérience
puis je trouve que j'ai bien joué quand
même après bon c'était difficile oui
franchement c'est de l'expérience donc
je suis assez contente de la lave et un
coup droit assez percutant non surtout
d'un côté puisqu'en fait il ya du vent
donc d'un côté elle essayait de mettre
plus de livres ce qui faisait que la
belgique reste difficile et de lotte me
rentrer dedans et la fouettent solide
sur les gens là régional de l'épreuve
s'incline 6 1 6 0
quant à la britannique son expérience
sur les courts martinique et progresse
aussi vite que sa maîtrise du français
j'adore martinique l'année dernière j'ai
joué ici et j'ai joué la finale et les
organisations sont très généreux et
agréable j'ai ador martinique